you are watching ColdFusion TV
welcome to another ColdFusion video to
gogo here if we take a look at the
reason explosion in the uses of civilian
drones you're in one of two camps
you're either excited about the
possibilities or just annoyed by the
drones if you're one of those people
that are annoyed this video will at
least make you appreciate the technology
so what am I talking about here what if
I told you that a team of drones builds
a bridge out of rope all by themselves
well exactly that just happened last
month let's get the story one of the big
selling points of drains is that they
can easily get to places where most
humans would rather not or just can't is
it possible that drones could actually
build objects that humans would have had
to put themselves in a risky situation
to do themselves the answer is maybe the
video you're watching was filmed at
Zurich flying machine Arena in
Switzerland it's a display of pretty
intricate aerial construction every knot
and braid of the seven point four meter
bridge was tied together autonomously by
these drains so that's right they did it
all by themselves with no help that's
cool and totally awesome but how does
this all work well the key is before
construction starts the room is
outfitted with motion capture devices
this motion capture equipment provides
positional measurements that are
communicated to the drains over a
wireless network there's also a set of
custom software that provides
sophisticated algorithms for estimation
and control so basically the motion
capture devices act like a pair of
external is for the drains to let them
see what's going on
so the drains don't ever bump into
anything you can also think of it like
an airport control tower situation okay
so a bunch of drones building a bridge
is nice but it's not really a bridge
until you can cross it so can you
as it turns out this bridge can easily
support a human's weight and I think
that's pretty amazing
the researchers involved in this
experiment say that this acts as a
demonstrator to show that airborne
drones are able to build load-bearing
structures at full-scale so there you
have it
drones are now able to start building
practical structures by themselves but
this isn't the first time this has been
done in 2011 a rather rudimentary
experiment showed that drones could
autonomously build towered structures is
this the future of construction of
flying robots building a wall
the robots developers were led by
Professor Raffaello Dandrea of the Swiss
Federal Institute of Technology in
Zurich
he says the multicopters use motion
sensors to position themselves but still
have to avoid each other while picking
up and placing the bricks in exactly the
right place it takes off and it flies
over to pick up a brick and it makes
sure that other vehicles that are flying
with bricks are not in its way so it
stays out of the way until it feels that
it can move into the space similar to
when you're driving a car and you want
to go into it into the freeway of course
this is fully autonomous the
multicopters recharged while waiting to
be tasked they would then pick up a foam
brick each weighing 500 grams and place
it exactly where instructed by a control
program known as the foreman so let's
take a look at the bigger picture here
what does this all mean what about in 20
years time can we scale this idea up so
that drones could carry even heavier
construction materials could aerial
construction theoretically mean the end
of conventional building methods that is
no bulky scaffolding and no projects
that are over budget or over time I
personally think that probably wouldn't
be the case but there might be a nice
halfway point where drones assist
construction at times on this both safer
and faster obviously they'll have to be
a few safety measures in place so it's
impossible for the drains to ever drop
things or collide with each other so I'm
gonna put it to you guys what do you
guys think do you think this is the
feature of construction or do you think
it's kind of pie in the sky let me know
your thoughts in the description below
anyway this has been to go-go you've
been watching ColdFusion give this video
a thumbs up if you liked it don't forget
to hit that subscribe button if you need
cheers guys and I'll see you again soon
for the next video have a good one
ColdFusion if we're thinking